Vertical assymptotes occur when the denominator is 0. This means you have to
solve x squared minus 7x plus 12 equals 0. So, we can factor this to x minus 4
and x minus 3 equals 0, which gives us the vertical asymptotes of x equaling 3
and x equals 4. To see if we have horizontal and oblique or slant asymptotes,
we need to look at the degrees of the polynomials in the numerator and the
denominator. As the numerator is just one, it has a lower degree than the
denominator, which means that we have a horizontal asymptote. So, what is this
asymptote? The horizontal asymptote tells me roughly where the graph will go
when x is really, really big. And we can see that in this case, when the x gets
bigger, that the function will move closer and closer to 0. So, the asymptote
is y equals 0. And for e, we have no slant or oblique asymptote.